foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
dark Brandon should transition into debt
Brandon
until Kevin McCarthy to stick the debt
ceiling straight up his [__] ass
that's what he should do
then I think that's what he should do
I'd rather he'll do the 14th or not who
knows I keep saying oh it'll be a long
Court battle well who cares who cares
how long the court battle will be as
long as he invokes the 14th
the United States can pay their bills
and we can move on get past this stupid
[__] but I my guess is Republican
Republicans are scrambling it feels like
to get the president at the negotiating
table again and the reason why is
because they want to continue this debt
ceiling fight next year goal here is to
raise the debt ceiling
pretend like the economy is going to
crash under Joe Biden to have an
economic effect
all the while only extending it until
next year and then next year had the
same stupid fight during an election
season
and frankly there is no better no better
reason to 14th this debt ceiling thing
which is unconstitutional on its face
it's dumb it's stupid
and really the the Republicans owned the
entire catastrophe here now the stock
market is still up this morning well
it's down now the Dow is down just a bit
stock market's still staying steady
Janet Yellen has said that
um the 14th
is kind of like a Hail Mary pass [__]
that [__] it's not a Hail Mary
give the ball to the running back and
let him run up the field and score a
goddamn touchdown the American people
don't give a [__] about your [__]
stupid fight over the debt ceiling they
don't care they don't they don't even
really give a [__] about deficits they
say they do sometimes
I am and by sometimes I mean when
Republicans aren't in power and they
need to gain power they care about
deficits but they don't they [__]
don't they elect these [__] to
give the richest of the rich the biggest
[__] tax cuts
that has ever been seen in this country
which has driven our national debt
higher than it ever has been before [__]
out of here we're not brain dead
[__] we can look at [__] and
know what the truth is and the truth is
is the reason why the deficit and the
debt is so goddamn high is because of
Republicans giving their Rich [__]
donors more tax cuts than than the
middle class and lower class Americans
[__] out of here
you people are still voting for
republicans
I mean we could talk all day about
Liberty rights and freedoms and how you
fascist are trying to take away people's
[__] autonomy in this country
or we could sit and talk about actual
substant issues policy issues that we
could actually
find some agreement on but you
[__] keep voting in these
fascists who want to continue
to create policy and to create
situations like this with the debt
ceiling where they [__] you
they continue to hurt you dummy
stop voting Republican it's stupid it's
really dumb I mean maybe in the future
when they pluck their head out of their
fascist ass and realize that their
policies suck that their ideas [__]
suck and we know that we know that they
suck and they know that we know that
they [__] suck then maybe they'll
change their ways but that's not in the
near future we're not talking about
Republican party oh my God waking up
tomorrow man we're a bunch of goddamn
Nazis we better stop this Nazi stuff
we better stop that stuff no they stand
around going well we're not Nazis you're
Nazis all the meantime neo-nazis actual
neo-nazis think the Republicans are
Nazis
and we're trying to have a [__] debt
ceiling debate with these people [__]
you don't negotiate with domestic
terrorists [__] them [__] them
Joe Biden dark Brandon DET Brandon
should sign the 14th Amendment and say
invoked [__] [__] you
[__] you and your debt ceiling
because it appears that the Republicans
are desperate here Pat McHenry is one of
the lead negotiators on this
you could almost consider him one of the
reasonable Republicans he doesn't wear
he doesn't wear the Nazi sash right he's
reasonable
[__] out of here [__] you Pat McHenry no
you don't get to tie the debt that you
[__] created the Appropriations
that you [__] created into new
spending cuts especially Top Line
spending cuts I'm sick of this [__]
trash
that we're the richest country in the
world and we can't afford [__] only
thing we can afford is to give the
biggest [__] tax breaks to the
richest [__] in this country
[__] you I'm sick of this [__] I'm sick
of this [__] we got to change the
narrative we I and I I know it sucks but
listen to me when I tell you this poor
white Americans and poor Americans in
general don't like this [__] they don't
but we have to do our job to create a
narrative so they'll wake the [__] up
and stop voting for people who keep
doing this [__] who keep using issues
like Bud Light cans and Target
to [__] get them to vote for [__]
boxes that [__] destroy their
communities
it's up to us it's it's our
responsibility
and it starts right now and it starts
with this [__] election Tim Scott's
on the stage right now
acting like he's gonna run for president
[__] out of here with this [__]
Rick excuse me Tim Scott I get him
confused you can see Tim Scott is on
stage right now pretending he's gonna
run for president
pretending
just like Vivek
is pretending to run
and it's all it's all in in an effort
Chris Christie's gonna get in this race
too sometime uh it's all in an effort to
keep Ron DeSantis out of the race yes
that's right I said it Tim Scott is
running
for president for Trump
I'm telling you
you [__] you [__] up you know I don't
give a [__] you can doubt me on this you
say I'm [__] nuts
he's running for Trump
he's going to run against Ron DeSantis
see this is how this works this is how
this works in primaries
there's some sort of incumbency and
really it's the cult that is creating
this incumbency of trump
and he just has to fend off number two
he doesn't have to fend off the rest of
them he just has to fend off a
challenger a Challenger
and we all know who that Challenger is
and the only reason why he is a
challenger Ron DeSantis is because Trump
talks about him
if Trump didn't say one word about Ron
DeSantis Rhonda santis wouldn't have a
chance in [__] hell okay got it
but Donald Trump sees Ron DeSantis as
his main arch enemy in this Republican
primary which is okay by me
frankly I hope they both destroy their
entire political careers from here on
out fine by me
but getting these other people in the
race aren't going to hurt Trump these I
can't even I can't even [__] tell you
how frustrating it is to watch people go
on [__] TV who have been doing this
for [__] decades decades and decades
and decades they're election analysts
and they're you you people are dumb as
dog [__] talking about how Trump's gonna
go down what are you talking about
his business had 17 felony counts 17 a
business fraud
and they're still behind him he gets
charged with 34 felonies in New York
they're still behind him you
[__] you you professional
analysts out there don't know how a
[__] cult works
it's it's frustrating as hell and you
you definitely don't know how
Association voting Works Jesus [__]
Christ
it's ridiculous listen Ron DeSantis is
not gonna be the nominee Tim Scott not
nominee Chris Christie Ashton Hutchinson
on and on it goes they're not gonna be
the nominees
Trump is the cult leader he has a
built-in incumbency for whatever it's
worth that's why he keeps saying I won
the election I won I won I won I won
that's what that's about is to create an
incumbency inside his brainwashed little
cult
and they're gonna do it I don't care
what he's charged with I don't give a
[__] I don't care if Georgia charges him
if Jack Smith charges him he will be the
[__] nominee because these people
have lost their [__] minds
they're freaking out over the weekend
over [__] Target having clothes in
their store so don't go in there if
you're scared of shirts that say queer
on it
our pride on it you [__] weirdos
don't go in the store if it's so
frightening to you [__] the what how
when the [__] did adult human beings
become so [__] scared of colors and
rainbows and words you weak ass pieces
of [__] Jesus Christ
I I I can't even tell you I don't even I
wouldn't even give a [__] if Target
started selling [__] swastika shirts
I just wouldn't go in there I just
wouldn't go in there and I probably
wouldn't even [__] bring it up just
wouldn't go in there wouldn't give my
money
they're not gonna do that because you
know um it's called capitalism and they
know what would happen if they put
swastikas on shirts
they know what would happen and they
know what's gonna happen when they put
Pride on shirts and rainbows on shirts
they know what's gonna happen
have you have you seen anheuser-busch's
stock they're like oh Ted Cruz says
because the the Bud Light thing was
really waning right
the Bud Light thing was wearing out oh I
was wearing thin
there's still people out there trying to
not drink Bud Light like physically
trying not to drink it that's so
pathetic that you people don't
understand how markets work you don't
understand how product works you're
trying your damnedest not to do
something
and you can't find a way around it
literally I was at an event and in some
[__] chucklehead didn't want a Bud
Light he was going to get a bush light
I'm like what the [__] that's the same
it's the yeah you dumb [__]
same [__]
that's that's not a boycott okay that's
not a boycott that's a hissy fit is what
it is that's a little [__] fit that
you're throwing there just like Target
listen do you think target all right
do you think target wants a bunch of
brainless [__] rednecks a bunch of
[__] boxes like Trump supporters and
manga in their stores I'm sure they're
like we're fine with not having those
people in our [__] stores
you're talking about 12 of the
population
we want to Market to the other 88
percent okay that's how [__]
capitalism works
how the [__] don't they know this
corporations aren't woke dummies
people just don't give a [__]
who you love or who you want to love and
they don't care if corporations show
their support in that rather it's
genuine or not most the time it is not
because Target gives just as much money
to [__] Republicans as they do
Democrats so to think that targets
somehow kind of woke Democratic
Corporation you're a dumb [__]
you are you are stupid as [__]
you're not aware of how [__]
capitalism Works in our two-party system
okay they all give to both sides
Republicans and Democrats in the worst
of times even
but here we are here we are but that's
what the cult's gonna do
the cult is gonna continue on pretending
like Bud Light doesn't exist an
anheuser-busch's stock isn't up they're
going to continue on like they're going
to take down Target
because of a few t-shirts that have
rainbows on them
they're gonna pretend like it and
they're gonna pretend like Donald Trump
is is it's all one big Witch Hunt he's
innocent he's the best the the best of
the best he's the greatest person ever
he had the greatest economy we were much
well better off under Trump than Biden
you [__] break nothing's changed
nothing's changed the only thing that's
changed is we have someone in charge
that isn't a [__] idiot
and has a steady hand
and that gives us [__] about the
American people
and frankly that's where this debate on
the debt ceiling should go about the
American people it should be about the
American people not about budget cuts
not about the Republican party not about
dark Brandon it should be about the
American people
and then the very end if the Republicans
don't do what the [__] they're supposed
to do which is raise the debt ceiling
which again it's a dumb [__] argument
I hope it I hope they don't do it and I
hope he 14's that son of a [__] [__]
them I'm I don't ever want to have this
F I don't ever want to do a rant about
this again
after this this this little couple weeks
we're gonna have I don't ever want to
talk about it I don't ever want to
[__] rant about it it's the dumbest
[__] thing that I've ever seen in my
life in in politics in Washington DC
we're fighting and holding the American
people and businesses hostage
over something that is unconstitutional
it's an unconstitutional fake [__]
argument
it's dumb it's dog [__] just like manga
it's not surprising that maga's the one
using it to hold the American people in
the economy hostage their economic
terrorists their domestic terrorists
their their religious terrorists and
their [__] economic terrorists
they're just 100 percent full-on
terrorists that's what they are
and they don't give a [__] about you and
when I say you I don't mean the people
who didn't vote for them I mean the
people who voted for these dumb sons of
[__] like Kevin McCarthy Marjorie
Taylor green and Lauren bobert frankly
you almost deserve what you're gonna get
with these stupid bastards
if you want to know the the full-on
truth you deserve what you're gonna get
you knew you heard him you heard him
talk
they were gonna they're gonna crash the
economy they don't give a [__] they're
like we're gonna crash the economy and
Joe Biden's gonna take the blame
they don't give a [__] about you
they they use they use
trans people to scare you they use
abortion to get you to go vote
that's what they do that's what they do
and and which none of the [__] that they
go do
in any any of these legislative bodies
whether it be the house the senate or
the state legislators
they don't they don't give a [__]
about you
and until you [__] pluck your head
out of your ass wake up and smell the
goddamn roses
you're not gonna understand why you
continue in rule White America to
continue to be set back and pissed off
it's because of them
Republicans the neo-nazis the ones you
keep voting for based on your fear and
your hatred
and we keep having these stupid fights
listen if the Democrats had the house
the debt ceiling would have done been
raised
done been raised
would have been done clean bill would
have been sent to the president's desk
and we would have had this fight later
on down the road
so maybe just maybe maybe just maybe
because Republicans keep giving us gift
after gift after gifted after gift in
the house to win the 2024 election
maybe just maybe if
the debt ceiling
gets 14th by debt Brandon then maybe
just maybe that is a gift that is given
to us
as a country so we never have to do this
stupid [__] again it's unconstitutional
it makes no [__] sense
and you're hurting Americans rather you
realize it or not oh well it doesn't
hurt Americans until we default [__]
you don't think people are sitting
around you don't think retired
[__] are sitting around you
don't think families are sitting around
that don't even have twenty dollars to
spare each month and worried about what
the [__] gonna happen they they
remember 2008 when the economy [__]
crashed they remember the pandemic when
they lost their [__] job what the
hell they gonna do
they remember they know
and you're gonna hold this over us [__]
out of here
[__] out of here
and again the Republicans own this [__]
they're the ones doing this
Republicans in the house are holding
America hostage and our economy hostage
they're holding a gun to Lady Liberty
so that they can cut their constituents
[__] benefits
they could cut government Top Line
spending by 22 percent
and let me tell you it's going to affect
their constituents the most
don't think so I mean I don't I don't
bring you the [__] data
I don't just pile it on you oh look here
here's this stat and here's this poll
and here's this statistic
it's the truth go find it
but it's the [__] truth
the Top Line 22 percent is going to
affect Republicans constituencies more
than any other
that's the [__] truth and the reason
why is because red States rely on
federal dollars and when you reduce Top
Line spending by 22 percent that means
less money goes to states that rely on
federal funding more than others who
don't
you stupid [__]
and that's just how they want it because
what they want is they want to squeeze
their own constituents to say see Joe
Biden is a bastard see what he did to
you he cut all your government funding
no he didn't
that's why Joe Biden must 14th this
goddamn thing that's what I'm calling
for
Joe Biden the president United States
debt Brandon needs to invoke the 14th
this afternoon when him and Kevin
McCarthy can't come to a deal [__] them
[__] them
you [__] and yeah am I calling
for it because they're holding
Republicans are holding their
constituents hostage yes and holding
their economies and Rural America and in
red States hostage yes and the reason
why folks is because they're going to
use this as a political tool
when they cut when they cut Top Line
spending by 22 percent they're going to
go back to their districts and blame
blame all the cuts that these people are
going to be pissed off about on Joe
Biden
are you listening to me
and they're gonna Stoke fear and outrage
over it
this is their [__] plan or crash the
economy and blame that on him
that's their that's their [__] plan
you got it
and that's why they want the spending
cuts on a top-line basis 22 percent tied
to the debt ceiling so they can raise
the debt ceiling for one goddamn year so
they can have this debate next [__]
year
in an election season mark my [__]
words Markham May 22nd Monday 12 23 p.m
eastern time Tony Michaels said if you
do this
if you tie 22 Top Line cuts to the debt
ceiling next year we'll have a debt
ceiling
debate and the Republicans will say you
did this last year and our constituents
suffered and they didn't get their
funding
[__]
they'll blame what they're doing
on the Democrats on Joe Biden in an
election season so Joe listen to me Joey
I know I know you know Washington really
well
but I'm telling you what the [__]
they're gonna do I can see it I can see
it all too clear why do you think Donald
Trump wants them to default he doesn't
want he he's going to be running against
jonben he wants the economy to be in
absolute shambles
he wants it to crash he wants people
lose their homes their jobs he wants
everything to go to complete [__] is
what he wants Kevin McCarthy's trying to
balance that between complete [__] and
blaming blaming 22 Top Line cuts on Joe
Biden
that's what he's trying to balance
that's what Pat McHenry is trying to do
[__] him
[__] him [__] you you [__]
and we should not let them get away with
it and yes do we do we have to outline
with with some rule manga people yeah
we're we're gonna have to it's it's
gonna be inevitable eventually like one
of these days one of these days these
issues are gonna catch us at a
Crossroads folks
it's gonna catch us at a crossroad
and if we if we if we don't stop lying
to our [__] selves
about this stupid [__]
listen red States take more federal
dollars than they give yes is it true
yes is it because Republicans run those
States absofucking lutely
because they're garbage they're [__] at
government they they're terrible at it
[__] terrible at it just look at any
[__] red state in the last 12 months
and look at the bills that they pass not
one of them for the people in those
States not one
frankly most of them have hurt their
[__] economies not help them
Jesus Christ Ron DeSantis he can't even
get migrant workers to work in his State
anymore houses aren't being built trucks
aren't being driven
all because of what what because you
want to own the libs and you hate wokism
meaning you hate people of color [__]
out of here with this nonsense
wake up and smell the goddamn coffee
so debt Brandon
listen to me
when you can't come to a deal this
afternoon
okay when you can't come to a deal this
afternoon with Kevin McCarthy or the
negotiators in the house
you 14th that [__] just do it don't be
scared of it it's for the American
people the American people will [__]
thank you
not only will they [__] thank you for
making sure that this fight is put to an
end but all future debt ceiling fights
are absolutely 100 percent dead done we
don't need to have this [__] anymore we
don't need to add distress
this depression
this Ridiculousness this stupid [__]
political theater [__] them [__] them
they should not be allowed to do this to
our economy to our country to our
democracy to our Republic
I'm a little hot this morning it is
Monday
[Laughter]
I always got the best rants doing that
I'm not patting myself on the back or
anything this is [__] episode 400.
can you believe that [__] how good was
that [__] rant for episode 400 huh
you goddamn right I bring the heat I
didn't even know exactly what I was
gonna say before I came on here I I
rarely I don't I don't script anything
since we're in episode 400 and just
being honest with each other I I might
as well just give you a little insight I
I don't I don't script anything so it's
not like a words in front of me that I'm
reading
and all that stuff is just thoughts that
are out of my brain
what I've been thinking about how I
think about them
and why it's so important to get our
messaging in our narrative correct and
on the right path I believe there's
nothing more important no data there's
no polls there's no one certain analyst
there's no certain piece of information
that is more important than messaging
that's it that's the most important
thing
in politics and elections especially in
our two-party system that we have in
this country super important
very important and that's where we've
gotten off the path that's why we lost a
lot of people in these red States but
we're gaining them back I'm telling you
as more and more people are going wait
wait what a second what are you saying
you want to do what
we're gaining them back
and we're gaining them back to Common
Sense
and it's gonna take a long hard work a
lot of work
to get this country back into shape to
get it to realize that yes we are a
constitutional Democratic Republic
and we are the government in this
Republic we elect these people to
represent us
and they are our employees we are their
boss
and if you don't do the work that we
elect you to do you're gone you're
[__] gone
your your term limit is now
we are the [__] government it is us
it is our democracy
that's what we need to focus on
we have to focus on pro-democracy ideals
pro-democracy 50 000 foot messaging it
is super important we are not going to
beat these fascists with polls and data
I'm telling you if you're coming at some
moglodyte in replies on Twitter or in
real life with some kind of data they
don't even know what the [__] you're
talking about okay
it's not even worth bringing up
I'm telling you this it's not worth it
if you want to make an argument about
something especially the debt ceiling
maybe just focus on the argument I just
made about 22 top 22 Top Line Cuts how
it's going to affect red States the most
the most because they're the most
reliant on federal funds
they get more federal funds than they
put in because they're broke because
Republicans run that state
and what Republican strategy is with Top
Line spending cuts is to affect their
constituents economically they want to
squeeze their constituents economically
their plan is to intentionally hurt them
so they can blame it on Democrats that's
their plan
that's their [__] plan and it's clear
to see
so do that don't [__] be like well
you know the this pole and that polling
oh this University there was a study
done over here who gives a rat's ass yes
those studies are done that's why we
know this information
but you don't have to go give them the
link of where you found your research
listen if you think these people are
gonna do their own research
you have not been paying attention
and we must we must contest these races
inside these states yes 2024 is the
biggest election of our democracy's
lifetime just like 2022
midterms were the biggest election in
our democracy's life then the most
important election in our democracies
Lifetime and then they're over now it's
2024. and it's time to keep saving our
democracy
and we have to do it by engaging
together
and we have to do it by being loud and
proud about liberal democracy that is
what we must do there is a through line
between all people who are not
Republicans who are not fascist
and I don't even say on the left because
a lot of people that aren't Republicans
aren't fascists aren't necessarily
leftist but there is a through line of
pro-democracy sentiment and there is a
coalition out there
and the greatest thing ever is we know
that there are more of us than there are
of them
that's what we have to remember we we
have not lost this fight
we have only begun this fight
and really the the wins that they have
had in some of these states is only is
only the quiet part out loud only giving
us ammunition for the next election to
win at The Ballot Box
so get ready get stoked get fired up and
come here every single weekday I'm
telling you you're not gonna get any
more [__] rant like I give no way no
way you tell me I keep telling people to
point out who the hell does what I do
show me show tell me who it is no one
does this not like I do it no one
there's not one [__] on the left
that does it like I do it
not one I mean there's some that are
close not like me
um
not with the heat I bring folks that's
why you should come here every single
weekday and you should subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube right
now you should like and you should share
this link on all your social media
speaking of social media follow us on
Facebook at Tony Michaels pod also if
you're watching on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels is where you can watch us every
single weekday on Facebook if you still
have a Facebook account
you can download every single episode as
well in the afternoon here's what
happens we do this show live and then I
take the audio version I do a few edits
to it
you know cut the front off cut the end
off make it kind of nice and neat if I
forget to turn on my microphone like I
did the other day I gotta fix that
little bit did you guys go listen to
that one you should you should go listen
to the one where I forget what the
episode is I could probably find out the
number and the episode where I didn't
have my microphone I had my microphone
on mute
but go list go listen to the one the
audio version and the video version and
you'll see the difference you'll see how
uh Tony does can do a little bit of
editing
a little bit just a little bit so go
download every single episode it's free
to download on Apple Spotify and Google
do that for me please while you're there
leave a great review also I want to
thank everyone on Twitch holy moly I
know I keep being astounded by this but
it it's getting it's getting better
every day
like we just got more followers just
this morning on Twitch and I I don't
know if you guys are coming from like
Facebook or something or if you guys are
just finding us on Twitch I have no idea
maybe that twitch chat can tell me if if
they're coming from YouTube are they are
is it organic I I have no idea
but we're almost up to 1200 followers
which is free to follow us on Twitch so
go follow us on Twitch number one it's
free
but but the subscriber count is going up
too we're almost to 200 subscribers
which doesn't sound like a lot
but it means a lot to us it means every
single every single subscriber means a
lot to us and here is how you can do it
for free right
here's what happens Amazon owns twitch
and if you have an Amazon Prime account
Amazon Prime gives you one free
subscription with Amazon gaming to
Twitch what you have to do is link your
Amazon Prime account and your Twitch
account together and give us that one
free subscription every single month and
you got to do it every month so if
you've done it before but haven't
renewed it in a while you just go in and
renew it it takes like three seconds if
you need the link you just go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com
and there's like the fourth button down
that says link Amazon and twitch and
that'll give you all the directions
it'll show you how to do it I want to
thank everyone out there because I know
a lot of people don't watch on Twitch
but if you are an Amazon Prime humor
user
and our goal is uh 200 so we need 15
more people 15 more people to hit our
our newest goal which is 200 subscribers
on Twitch we're at 185 right now
currently
so if you're out there and you have a
Prime account you could do that that
would help us out greatly to get to our
goal of 200 but I want to thank you
because it is truly a great way
um for you guys to support the show
without costing you any extra money it's
a great way for us to get paid without
costing you a single dime I'm not always
the biggest Amazon fan but I'll tell you
what it is a very very neat way that you
can support us as creators every single
weekday not just watching us because
that's the biggest that's the biggest
support is to watch us from beginning to
end to share the link to like it on all
the platforms to go follow us on all the
platforms
but if you can link your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account it gives
us a few dollars every single month if
you renew it every single month and it
is fantastic and I appreciate all the
support you're the best audience in the
world don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC we
was 50 strong in number some patriots
ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
near on a Natty light hope it don't rain
tomorrow so we can Circle the city again
years
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
I spotted a troll on Twitch you're in
Port [__]
[Laughter]
there's someone over there saying we're
anti-capitalist and you obviously do not
listen to this show you don't listen to
the show I'm not one of those kind of
leftists I'm not one of those kind of
letters I mean I'm not I'm not exactly
uh
the biggest fan of capitalism in some
systems like the Health Care system not
a fan of it I don't think anyone should
be able to [__] profit off someone's
sickness yeah okay oh okay
well let me tell you something I I'm a
realist
I'm a realist is what I am I don't like
to call it moderate it's not moderate
because I'm a [__] liberal capital L
[__] liberal and I'm for Choice I'm
for Liberty I'm For Freedom that's what
I'm for and you know what if you want to
be a dumb [__] on Twitch and you
want to come into a chat room and say
really stupid [__] about someone you
haven't been watching it at all go ahead
be my guest it's fun because they're
gonna eat you the [__] alive because
they know me they've been here the
entire time the entire time oh no Robin
don't worry about the troll leave the
troll leave the troll making a fool out
of themselves
thank you
a [__] fool so have at it have at it
[__]
have at it but I I love I love the uh
the chat on Twitch it's a little
different than on YouTube
and you guys should go check it out
seriously you should go check it out
every once in a while go watch on Twitch
um Robin is uh our moderator over there
she works hard moderating thank you
Robin and we have I I think big Steph
fan
um has was like one of the first ones to
watch on Twitch like every day there was
a lot of people but uh CB was also
um CB was also one of the first ones
there's like three people in the twitch
chat and when we first started maybe
four or five Watchers and then in the
last couple months it's just exploded
yes Edward I see you're there too
you're there on Twitch too so I'm
telling you this is
um and I and I know it it seems
like I keep talking about twitch but I I
I'm telling you it really means a lot it
means a lot to me it means a lot to Gabe
um because we have our own separate
patreons and I I like I try to be
transparent with you guys we like how we
make money because this is what we do
this is what we do
to try to make a living this is how this
is our job I don't like to call it a job
because I don't really consider it a job
um I I think job is something that you
go do that you're probably not good at
that you don't [__] really like and
you just do it for the money and that
isn't what this is
I love doing this I love coming here
every single this is my [__] happy
place if you want to know the honest
[__] truth
this is my happy place to talk to you
people every single weekday for two full
hours yesterday we had a lot of fun in
the patreon chat and speaking on patreon
I opened it up last night to the public
and there was like I don't know 500
people there
uh for the patreon only but I opened it
up to everyone so everyone can see what
patreon's about I do that every once in
a while so give the public a chance to
see what the hell it is right what the
hell does the patreon do what is it
what's the Sunday rant well we did that
yesterday and it was uh it was great
there was a lot of people there we got
new patreon members we've had new even
this morning so thank you very much for
that but that that's how we make money
I have my patreon Gabe has his patreon
for what was that and then we share
revenue for the show so like anytime you
guys buy merch or if you give a
subscription or if you give like a a tip
jar if you guys I know I know I have
super chat on YouTube because we're not
[__] monetized because YouTube
[__] hates my guts what am I gonna do
I don't know what to do so if you want
to give like a super chat I can't do it
in the chat because they're bastards but
you can go to the Tony michaels.com you
can drop it in the tip jar and that goes
to me and Gabe for the show so um thank
you so much for all your guys support
not just the monetary support because
that means a heck of a lot to us and our
families it really does but when you're
here every single day you're listening
every single day when you send us stuff
when you send us DMS we try to get we
try to get to it we try to do that so we
really we really like you
um
what's the
what I thought two plus two from four
bucks is that are you talking about the
the subscription on Twitch yeah that's
kind of a [__] up thing right so again
I'm not always a fan of Amazon and how
this [__] works with creators because
twitch the subscription is 4.99 I think
that's what you're talking about Toby
the subscription is 4.99 right now when
you do it with your Prime account twitch
gets the 499 from Amazon which Amazon
owns twitch kinda weird not gonna lie
it's [__] kind of [__] up
but here's what happens the 499 they
take half of it twitch takes half of it
and then there's processing fees on top
of that so then we get like two dollars
and seven cents or something like that I
think it's what I figured I figured it
out one day it's like two dollars and
seven cents two dollars and eight cents
some [__] like that is what we get yes
it's not a lot but you know what the
cool thing is if you're already paying
for Prime you're already doing that it
doesn't cost you anything to give us a
couple bucks a month all you got to do
is do the thing where you subscribe and
then you re-subscribe each month and
it's a great way so as much as I don't
like Amazon maybe maybe I don't like it
as much as I should maybe I don't even
like twitch as much as I should because
I don't fully understand it because it's
more for streaming and I I don't
consider myself a streamer really
and you can consider myself a show host
kind of so but you know
any money is money and it helps support
our families and it helps support the uh
the soda streaming habit of this guy
Gabe Sanchez welcome to the show my
friend hey I gotta find I gotta find
places to get my uh my CO2 because Bed
Bath Beyond is going under so I can't go
there anymore
wait wait wait is that where you were
getting on your SodaStream CO2
that's where they sell them so then you
can they have is it a specialized
canister or some [__] uh no no it's just
well it's I mean the canister that
they they sell like the like SodaStream
specifically right goes in their unit
right but so I just use any other one
that you got to use no no I mean like I
know some people that have like a CO2
tank underneath you buy them online
they're tech savvy guy what the hell is
wrong with you why would I buy online
that's that's so much waste so what I
have to do is I I buy why is it wasteful
to buy online tell me why because what
do I do with all the empty canisters
oh you don't even recycle them yeah so
they have a recycled stack them up glue
them to the wall behind you those things
are [__] weapons man they are really
they're like yeah they are dense pieces
of metal because they're holding so
you'll recycle them surely there's a
recycle yeah but then at the same time I
use the empty ones
to recycle and get a discount for a
brand new one
oh man this is like um this is like
propane tank exchanges I mean it
literally is so we were looking at some
patio furniture and there's the ones
with the fire table like in the middle
oh yeah I'm a [__] hillbilly man I I
never cooked on [__] guess everyone
knows it when I I posted a picture of
Mother's Day I was cooking with charcoal
because that's how you [__] cook all
right if you're gonna cook outside
what the hell what just go cook inside
if you're gonna cook and if you're gonna
cook on gas what the [__] wrong with
you all right let's go cook inside are
we cooking outside but these gas tables
and you gotta have the tank and you
gotta hook them up I'm like what the
[__] man just cut you some wood split
some wood and throw it on a fire make
you a fire yeah you gotta have hey what
do you have this guess so I don't
understand the whole
oh man you're you're you're talking I
don't know crazy stuff to me I mean
unless there's a reason why like if
there's a reason for wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait there's gotta
be there's gotta be a service somewhere
online that you can buy these soda
streams from and send your canisters in
to get credit there's gotta be there's
just gotta be that means I gotta wait I
gotta
all right so no no what I'm saying is
you open up like an account with these
people right yeah and then they you buy
the first round of Sodastream right
right and then they send you a box to
send the [__] empties back in and you
send those back and you get credit
that's what I'm saying and then your
next purchase you got the credits there
might be I mean I wouldn't be surprised
if there was a place I could go to in
the LA area and be like hey here are my
empty ones refill them or they have an
exchange program like Christ you're in
that's right you're in Los Angeles
there's got to be some place out there
yeah it's not like you're in the middle
of [__] nowhere no yeah but the also
the benefit of going to bed bath beyond
was I had those 20 off coupon so I can
use them on everything so here it comes
here it goes so this I mean look I'm
gonna get the discount on the Sodastream
but then I'm also going to get the 20
discount plus I had like five dollar ten
dollar twenty dollar twenty percent you
know all these things those are what
that's the key so your soda string you
have it is gonna get really expensive is
what you're saying just like this
[__] life there it is there is uh
yeah it's gonna get real expensive and
then I'm not gonna be able to have sodas
I'm not gonna have CO2 anymore oh oh hey
the chat's saying target has them target
has them baby oh man that there you go
all right
I just got I just got a I was saying the
other day I just got a brand new Target
in my area so there you go man target it
is Target it is because really in L.A
they would be Tarjay here in Missouri
it's Target yeah but also when I lived
in Chicago that was it was like we're
going to Target like it was just you
know you want to sound a little bit
better that is crazy all right and at
first you're like wait what's Target and
they're like you don't know Tarjay jeez
what are you what are you one of them
rednecks uh-huh so
demoglinites thought they were going to
get rid of Bud Light they still are they
still are trying to they're still trying
to make it relevant so takers did you
see the Ted Cruz like I'm gonna open
investigation but I saw that I saw that
last week and then I saw there was
another clip that came out today here's
the thing I started working on it what
was that that was around this thing and
it was like the bloodline issue yeah
yeah because it's like dude I thought we
had established this right like oh Jesus
we've and I don't even know why we got
to keep talking about this but whatever
well it's because they have no they have
non-issues they're a non-issue party
right and that they they're a culture
War they make issues out of nothing it
would be great if they if Ted Cruz and
these mongodites would have the same
energy for like I don't know kids
getting murdered in elementary schools
yeah
that would be that would be really cool
if they had the kind of energy that they
had for Bud Light as they have here I
mean I
if I was Ted Cruz I'd be very careful
about what he's saying right he's making
very defamatory claims
by saying that Bud Light intentionally
marketed their beer to younger people
right
so well and the other thing too is I
think what Ted Cruz
um is discounting here is that it is
unlikely that the Senate will call
anyone from Bud Light or Anheuser-Busch
to answer these questions really
unlikely that the cinema well
Jim Jordan and Jim Comer like oh my God
Janet Janet bullet China China laptop
Bud Light China trans people
we're gonna have a hearing and we're
gonna get Bud Light to I don't know talk
about their marketing strategy I
wouldn't be surprised if they found a
whistleblower from Bud Light that's paid
by cash Patel that's paid by cash Patel
or James O'Keefe
what James O'Keefe paid a whistleblower
no but he always has those goddamn
videos yeah where he's like you know
project Veritas and then now he's got
his own thing because he kicked out a
project Veritas now oh why was that why
was he kicked out of a project so it's
almost like they were you know uh
maliciously editing uh videos to tell a
different narrative that weren't true
you know what that's funny because
room uh what was it Saturday with Laura
Loomer was it so yeah oh my God that
crazy sack of [__] so Laura Loomer is in
this Twitter space and she is just
absolutely losing her mind I mean just
whining and complaining whining and
gabling and I think it was uh Joe was
the one like you get an award for that
right he was like yeah
some bang-up editing you did the some of
the best video editing ever over there
he's like you should get an Academy
Award for the amount of editing that you
guys did
and she was losing her mind and then
they brought me up to the stage and of
course they love when I come in there
because I just like I just raise the
temperature of the room but they were
all fighting like they were literally
like Ron DeSantis lies about Rhonda
Santos and then lies about Trump like
they were just eating each other it was
so beautiful I couldn't stop listening
to be quite honest to just these people
eating each other I was like this is
great A bunch of Ashes calling each
other Liars they they messaged me and
they're like hey you want to come in and
chat or like speak and I was like yeah
sure so like you know I sent a message
and requested and then I was busy doing
all the stuff and I was texting you and
listening to the space at the same time
and I got to a point where I was like
I don't think anyone needs me to be in
space right now because they're doing a
great job themselves well I actually
when I came up to the stage and they
wanted me to speak Suleiman said Tony go
ahead and I was like well I I don't
really have any notes
um because you people are doing a
bang-up job just burning each other down
with outright lies about each other it's
[__] fantastic I love it I said I
hope you keep going this is what we
really want we want you to fight like
this is we know we're gonna win you did
you did get them to unite on Chris Chris
that is true yeah
that was their comment they were like
he's fat but Donald Trump isn't I I how
much does how much more
Brown that's true they're all chubby
have you seen the video of him in the
[__] Diner Ron DeSantis yeah oh my
God
so my comment was they said just be
yourself and then I said horrible idea
what a bad idea
oh a lot of people okay
Edward Edward had the greatest comment
let me let me see if I can find it
oh Edward is
um a great Fanny I think he's over there
on Twitch he's in the twitch yet it
wasn't the twitch chat for a while maybe
he's back on YouTube I think he's on
YouTube too but um they said just be
yourself and it was a horrible idea
here's Ron DeSantis uh wow
do we know what Diner this is it says
Diner day or no it's like it's in quotes
no so it's probably not I don't know
it's it's if let's say this it's famous
enough
in New Hampshire in New Hampshire
because it's got a lot of photos and I
think it's like Rudy Giuliani on the
photo up right there's been a lot a lot
of scumbags coming up
something something
like I'm trying to see if there's like
yeah it's I I don't know I don't know
but the point is is this is a diner
right now most the time when humans not
fascist Androids in human suits walk in
the diners but when humans walk in
diners they act like
normal [__] right now this is
this is Ron DeSantis doing his best to
play normal listen this how are you
doing wow look at this Hi how are you
guys good to see you so what do you got
so what do you got what is it what the
hell what does that mean what do you got
uh [__] food dude it's a diner what
the [__] you mean he's like me no eight
me no eat human food before what is
human food what is human it's like in
it's like in The Matrix where he's like
all right I want to you know learn this
skill and at the same time he's like all
right what is food
historically food has been used for a
variety of humans and uses where one
wakes up in the morning and has
breakfast
does chat GPT run Ronda Santos is that
what no that's a good question he had
the chat GPT upgrade I don't know let's
let's listen to see if he does go right
over here oh yeah over here yeah good
deal wow
oh wow crowded huh yes breakfast gummy
is it's a Giant Food many many people
have congregated in the diner
whoa many humans using silverware to eat
human food it's amazing oh my God let me
see if I can turn on my senses and see
how are you doing it smells really good
I'll tell you that
senses senses smell it smells like food
it smells good I'll tell you that smooth
feels good what no no food smells good
yes that's what I mean
what the [__] why is this guy such a
real how much time do you think he spent
choreographing his appearances to be
like okay I gotta comment on the food I
gotta say hello to someone he's like
wait wait wait you're saying he's
practicing these lines I think he's
practiced these lines oh my God which
doesn't make it any better but I
honestly think that he's unable to
improvise I think the only times we've
ever seen Ron DeSantis has been when
he's prepared he's done uh when he you
know uh uh debates been prepared he had
a speech he knew his talking points he
knew the script he he spoke at different
events right uh he's he's talking about
different bills things like that as
Governor those things were
normal normal in the sense of they were
rehearsed speeches that he would give
and he didn't have to have a human
interaction right but when he does these
ones where it's not a one-on-one
situation or a one to many this is like
many to one right this is like re this
is what they call retail politics yeah
this is where you go in Shake Hands kiss
babies and or more if you would probably
do it and and Ron DeSantis I think is
really struggling because I think he's
choreographed with people to be like I
mean even if you looked at the rehearsal
that he did with uh with Byron Donald's
and
Matt Gates of 2018
he's breaking down like he doesn't know
like if he can't do something a certain
way then he gets all flustered and he's
like oh why can't I do it that way
that's what he said that's what he did I
want to eat pudding with my fingers okay
that's what I want to do so when I think
that when he does these moments where he
walks into a diner he walks into a
public space it's many people to one
instead of one to one or one to many the
relationship right he's not speaking to
a crowd of people he's not speaking to
one person rehearse these things if he's
got all these human interactions coming
at him all at once like it's sensory
over all over the Android and I think
he's really having a hard time
improvising because he's like all these
stimuli like someone here smell huh what
oh you said baby what's your name what
oh my God people crowds what is this
place oh it says Diner on the outside I
don't know what a diner is uh right well
watch watch
okay so you're gonna watch him turn
around here and he literally I don't
know who cues him on hey stop doing what
you're doing and go talk to people it's
really he's like oh okay let's get
started it's really weird but watch his
interaction with this one he he
verbalizes every kid right
where he's like oh we're going over here
okay it's like dude just do it just walk
over there man watch watch this this is
this is the most awkward part and then
when he introduces himself it's even
more Awkward watch this so we'll do it
okay okay
what what's your name listen if you want
to ask someone their name like in a
normal human interaction like hi my
name's Ron
hi I'm I'm Rhonda santis yeah hey I'm
Ron I mean you know obviously I'm Ron
right and then it would be like I'm Tim
right like that would be the that would
be the natural instinct you have to you
have to look at this and say like right
any person would be like hey I'm Gabe
good to meet you what's your name like
I'm gay who are you right oh great great
you made you awesome like blah blah you
know and if you want to remember the
name you might say the name a couple
more times and like a statement to be
like great well you're not gonna we
can't expect power I just remember every
single person no no no no no no it's not
the actual interaction like normally
yeah like hi I mean even even Joe Biden
would be like hi I'm Joe that's like a
natural human even though you know they
know who you are yeah yeah right they I
already know you know who I am but I'm
introducing myself so you tell me your
name like this is a normal human thing
well also because it's like you would
come in and be like hey I'm Ron good to
meet you what's your name right because
the other one I mean I guess you could
do it the other way where they're like
hi I'm selling or like what's your name
and they're like I'm John and you're
like great my name's blank that's like
that's that's a weird interaction
because now you're coming back like yeah
I [__] know who you are but if you
start me like hey I'm so and so what's
your name or how you doing or whatever
and then they answer and then you go
from there right I mean it makes sense
right you're engaging right you
introduce and you say hi I'm Ron
but if someone tells you their name like
hey I'm Tim do you say okay no I know
you're like nice to meet you Tim like
how the [__] he prepped for this
okay man I think he did okay that's a
name that's a name has has anyone ever
seen uh
uh the show if anyone's a Nathan Fielder
or uh a Nathan Fielder fan everyone's
watched Nathan for you on Comedy Central
years ago but also on HBO he just had a
show called The Rehearsal okay and the
way the rehearsal works is
he uh helps people deal with a situation
that they're like there's a roadblock
right an interaction to have with
someone right to tell someone this or to
uh reveal something and
and in order to make sure that it's as
successful as possible they rehearse it
so
in the show they do some crazy things
where they reconstruct the apartment
that this one guy's in they reconstruct
a reconstruct a bar that's based in New
York City that I actually went to last
year uh that's now been relocated all
the way up to Portland
um the show works on this premise it's
incredibly it's incredibly awkward to
watch
and and cringe at times but it's so
masterfully done and how like
what's real and what's not real but in
the show
there's all these different scenarios
where they rehearse again and again and
again and again to get the cue down be
like you're gonna turn right and there's
gonna be the bartender you're gonna turn
left and there's gonna be two people at
a table and then two people at a table
and that table's open you're gonna grab
that table here's a ticket for pizza
you're gonna go get the pizza these are
the talking points we're gonna see how
successful and it becomes this like
decision tree of like how well the
conversation goes and then at that
moment in which they finally do in real
life have that interaction that person
can best know how to navigate the
conversation without it being like this
whole thing's an unknown right and I
feel like Ron DeSantis in this moment
this was a like rehearsal moment where
he practiced and practiced and practiced
and practice like look you're gonna
smell some things there's a kitchen okay
there's hooks they're cooking food
You're Gonna smell baking and eggs
coffee and they're like when you walk in
if you're gonna comment on food comment
on a specific type of food don't just
say you're cooking it smells smells like
a cooking yeah it's
you got coffee I'll take a cup you got
bacon that smells great I like to order
some right let's get it to the table
meat like human food we order human food
typical things because people work on
specifics not generalizations right
because it's weird when you do that like
when you're like my name's Tim and he's
like okay like right General is you want
to be like oh hey I'm so and so good to
meet you like what are you up to today
like are you here with your family like
just right what did you what did you
order what are do you come here often I
want to know what's good to eat right
what's good on the [__] menu I
haven't eaten today
oh you recommend the breakfast sandwich
grapes
whether or not he does order it it's
just the [__] act of engaging with a
potential voter right to be like hey man
or just a human just like doing human
stuff I'm normal like J like the guy's
gonna short circuit and it's gonna
happen more and more and more and
despite the fact of how well he
rehearses for this [__] he's gonna
sound so [__] awkward because they
can't control this scenario as much as
they want
they can't they can't block him and
buffer him from other people the the
other thing too I think is important and
as he [__] this up and ends he does
these weird interactions
Trump's going to bury him on this Chris
Christie's definitely going to bury him
on this yeah like right because I was
trying to convey this in the first 30
minutes that Trump is has some sort of
incumbency and the reason why is because
of how Colts work and that's why he
keeps saying I didn't lose he was
posting on true social this morning that
he won both elections by a landslide and
oh the last one is rigged so he's trying
to hang on to someone come and see here
which he's the front runner he's going
to be the nominee yeah but all the other
people like uh Tim Scott is getting in
the race today they're all fighting for
number two not for number one they're
all fighting for number two and the
reason why Ron descent is literally is
number two right now is because Trump
keeps talking about him
okay Trump keeps talking about DeSantis
he's not going to talk about Christy or
Tim Scott at this point he's talking
about DeSantis which makes the
scientists low totem pole number two and
everyone else is going to try to chase
number two which means they're going to
attack around the Santas that's what's
gonna happen that's how it works that's
how it works but here
it gets worse I don't know how in this
last 10 seconds but it gets worse like
literally you just watch around to say
look at his face this guy just got
introduced to Tim right he's already
sick of seeing this guy look at him yeah
he's like I'm already sick of seeing you
he's like you're too close right you're
too close proximity sensor proximity
sensor proximity sensor right alert
alert alert disengage now watch out
smile watch him disengage because it is
more Awkward than the my name's Tim okay
watch him disengage I'm wonderful it's
great to be up in New Hampshire
he almost did the lab did you see that
yeah
like because they told him they told him
don't do that again don't do that don't
ever open your mouth
and he almost did it he almost did it
you saw that like it was just like they
must have gave me nothing so I can
unhook my jaw here right you know
and they're like don't do it oh my God
Rhonda santis you're a dumbass and I
hope you get in the race
keeps it going man Ron I've been telling
you get in the [__] race man
um okay so
um there was some other video over the
weekend that we missed
um and and there's a few stories that I
want to go over okay yeah
you've heard of Marjorie day the green
right
I mean yeah a few times a couple times
last regret totally yeah
you know that she's getting a divorce
right
did you know
she's pregnant
I I don't know that
um
people are saying but did you know if
she is pregnant it's probably Brian
Glenn's baby but did you know that Brian
Glenn is a drag queen I did know that
did you know this yeah what the [__] so
apparently he was some kind of reporter
in Dallas right before we're going to
use that term reporter right well I mean
you know whatever so
Franklin he's reporting in Dallas and
he's got pantyhose on he's got a wig on
he's in drag let's just say he's in Drag
and I mean I you know whatever you want
to do I'm not I'm not opposed to people
being in drag to be quite honest I just
don't like people who get dressed and
dragged trying to delineate legitimize
and
basically
take away their [__] freedom of
speech to dress and drag yeah what is it
what is it with these Republicans and
that they love dressing up in drag yeah
right it's almost like it's almost like
they did it during the 90s and 2000s and
it wasn't a problem no nobody had a
problem now it is they were happy to put
on the pantyhose and the earrings and
and [__] makeup and lipstick and the
wig and and everything they were even
you know they even put on fake boobs
right all the stuff to make it look real
for whatever bit they were doing they
were totally fine didn't make them gay
and it certainly wasn't converting and
transitioning children that they were oh
my God the kids
well I'm going to show you this clip of
Brian Glenn and drag
um it's kind of funny because he doesn't
like the shoes but he loves the
pantyhose I'm not kidding that's what he
says listen this
[__] I could tell you I don't think I
think a lot of people up now they're all
hashtag I am of course come and check it
out here start something Saturday I'm
kicking these shoes off but I may keep
the pantyhose on they're still kind of
good actually I'm not gonna pee in them
I promise I'm sitting back to the studio
did he say he wasn't gonna pee in him
yeah does he think people pee in
pantyhose is that what he thinks I don't
know for a moment it seemed like Brian
Glenn was
understanding part of the issue that
women have wearing high heels being like
God damn my feet hurt I gotta take them
off I gotta wear flats I want to walk
around my bare feet right like it's
almost like for a slight moment he's
like oh I kind of understand
this one part of being a woman right
right
well
so pager takes post to that video Yeah
and a lot of people are like whoa what
the [__] you know because you're like in
Marjorie Taylor green dating this guy
marjor Jay the Green's the one out
advocating for the I don't know
execution of these people and you doubt
me on that I mean she hadn't said that
at her mouth but I'm going to show you
another video that she probably loves
loves the pastor that I'm gonna show you
and would probably advocate for all his
sermons I'm going to show you a video
here in just a second that I think
Margaret Taylor green would love
so hang on to that idea but Marjorie
Taylor green decided not to get rid of
Brian Glenn I mean you would think if
drag queens were so horrific and this
idea that if you ever got in dragged
then you must be some kind of other
right I mean that's what she's saying
isn't it I mean that's what she says
yeah that's what she says right she
called she called Dylan Mulvaney the
biggest pedophile ever I think is what
she said something like that the faming
um Noah Mulvaney but she tweets at
Patriot takes who put this video online
yes yes beautiful she said I'm literally
loling
Brian Glenn
dressed and dragged for Morning News in
Dallas years ago reporting on an
upcoming local theater production and
the morons over at Patriot take thinks
this is an attack
Ryan loves the throwback and is
reposting haha with the Emoji the left
is so stupid
okay so the problem is is that the left
knots do because the left doesn't give a
[__] if Brian Glenn dresses in drag what
we give a [__] about is that the laws
are for thee and not for me type [__]
right that's what we give a [__] about
you hypocritical [__] fascist that's
what we give a [__] about that you want
to legislate certain things out of
existence but you laugh at it when when
it's it's okay for you to do it right
it's okay for you to do it but not for
someone else to do it that's the thing
that really pisses us off that's the
thing that gets underarm [__] skin
Marge but let me show you
let me show you a clip
because as much as uh this Marjorie
Taylor green thing you know I want to
wait somebody brought up can you go back
to that tweet somebody somebody brought
up a a good point here
did she say
okay she says loline right so I didn't
catch that at first but uh laugh out
loud laugh out loud
I'm literally laugh out louding
that's no Marge that's not how that
that's not how that that it would be an
acronym words
laughing out loud but you know again
again this is deflection right this is
deflection from their [__] bigotry
yeah let me show it to you in full force
here let me show you in full vision
because I I don't think people are
really understanding exactly what these
[__] white Christian
nationalists are talking about when
they're attacking the lgbtq community
and thinking and and absolutely it's
bone-ended stuff thinking that drag
queens are trans people which they can
be but not all trans people are drag
queens not all anyways yeah you get it
we're not dumb enough in this audience
to know that but all Republicans are
fascists well
and idiots listen they may not all be
Nazis but the Nazis think they're Nazis
seems appropriate speaking of Nazis
here's this guy
um his his name is Grabber his last name
is he's Pastor Grabber I'm not just like
he's grabbing that water bottle there
yeah well he's got a hold of it he's
gotta hold it listen to what this
[__] scumbag says I showed this on a
patreon last night but this the reason
why Republicans are out there
legislating in in in States
to wipe lgbtq people out of existence
this is what they're doing this is their
goal listen what this [__] says
this is a [__] they're listening to this
is the [__] they believe
to any parents that would have their
child
uh have a have a transgender surgery
done on them any parent that would do
that they just need to be shot in the
back of the head
did you cancel that did you catch that
huh did you did you catch that yeah huh
yeah oh oh this is probably going to be
a what was that I'm sure because there's
several moments in this clip where
you're like what what was that so first
off he's lying
he's lying almost every there is no
[__] surgery that happens for minors
no that's the same it's the same thing
that uh that Ted Cruz is pushing right
he's like these eight-year-olds are
getting surgery no no they're not no no
they're not where you're getting that
idea I mean I know that you're not smart
they're lying also it also proves that
you can go to Harvard and still be a
[__] idiot well that is true I don't
know where the uh Grabber Pastor Grabber
I can't believe that's his [__] name
bastard Grabber Pastor Grabber when he's
beat up Pastor Grabber oh my God okay it
gets I I know that seems pretty intense
right just to shoot people in the back
of the head parents of children right
parents of children uh who who have
identity crisis whatever it may be he
wants them to just be executed by being
shot in the back head it gets it gets
worse listeners
they need to be convicted in trial
and immediately shot in the back of the
head okay and then we can string them up
above a bridge God damn and so that the
public can see the consequences of that
kind of wickedness okay I'm not sure if
you I'm not sure if you know I'm not
sure if you know
there is a time in our country okay
and I I don't know I don't know if
people know this but there's a time in
our country in certain states in the
South that if a black person would do
something that white supremacist thought
was out of line they would kill them
and then they would hang them sometimes
they would kill them by hanging them and
they would take pictures with these as
trophies and it wasn't just and it was
to show the other black people in the
South when you get out of line this is
what happens this is white supremacy
101 folks this is fascism
101 that this [__] is calling
for not only execution but the public
display of their bodies by lynching them
by from Bridges
to to tell the masses we're coming after
you next I don't know if you know that
or not but it gets worse man I know I
know it sounds like it shouldn't but by
God it does let's listen to Pastor
Grabber here
do more uh want more genocide
and so there should be no excuse to not
put these people to death
no excuse whatsoever
wait for it go ahead and turn to
Ephesians chapter number four yeah and
let me tell you there are very very few
people people out there in the world
today that are actually fighting the
spiritual fight I want you to go ahead
and find me another preacher in Spokane
to preach the message where they said
that these that these child molesters
that these child butchers that these
facts all the lgbtq people people that
desire strange flesh
that they should all be put to death in
a public execution by the government
find me the preacher that says that
I think we found him to be quite honest
I think that's what we're looking at
right here so let me let me this is
disturbing as [__] right yeah this is
crazy [__] I can't even believe that
we're not that Jesus Christ I can't even
believe that this is the most viral
[__] video on the internet right now
and the reason why it's not
is because people like Martin take the
green b-rot Lauren bobert people like
Brian Glenn people like Donald Trump
people like Ron DeSantis people like
Mike Parsons the governor of Missouri
people like Bill Lee the governor in
Tennessee every single Republican who's
who who's who who
not only supports fascist ideas but is
trying to legislate people out of
existence agree with this [__]
and until you don't agree then you do
agree that's the cold hard facts let me
tell you something I'm gonna keep saying
it over and over
Republicans may not think they're Nazis
but the Nazis the Nazis think you're
[__] Nazis okay you got it which
makes you a [__] Nazi this guy's
amazing also the fact that it you're if
you're not speaking out against these
Nazis and you're in the Republican party
that makes you by association a [__]
Nazi you goddamn right now is this
person gonna hide behind the First
Amendment absolutely he's gonna hide
behind the First Amendment but frankly
to me
he's not he's not exercising the First
Amendment here calling for genocide
calling for genocide yeah this is hate
speech this is calling for genocide of
an entire group of people is what he's
just open execution right of these
people it's [__] crazy and and family
members and others like that is that is
where
these people that have that associate
themselves with the Republican party and
they're like yeah you know what the uh
ideologies and the things that are
believed are are definitely not on the
Democratic party they're in the
Republican Party
and
it's it's not free speech it's hate
speech it's exactly what this it's what
the Republican party wants they're
[__] riling up their base they're
getting them agitated getting them you
know using fear mongering talking about
how these these uh the trans Community
or drag queens are going to
uh convert your children and transition
them and cut off their dicks and all
like it's wild [__] man let's watch it
Shelley makes a good point on Facebook
she says what happens to Thou shalt not
kill Shelly um I know you you want to
believe that these Christians believe
Christian ideals but they they they
don't they're the problem is is that
these these Theocratic Nazis these yeah
these white Christian nationalists
aren't actually Christians they're using
this religion and they're using the
brainwashing power of religion
to absolutely bring people over to their
murderous ways what it's what Hitler in
the Nazis did in Germany would you call
them I'm trying to think like would you
call them a Sino or would you call them
a rhino
you know
like are they Christian a name only or
are they religious you know it's it's
kind of funny you say that because
um the Nazis and we had
um we had we had a great guest on last
last week or the week before been a hit
and he was talking about how
um the Nazis were using the word
socialist and socialist ideas to attract
people to their [__] hatred right
they were using they were using a
certain amount of populism to attract
people so that they could brainwash them
of their hatred and that's what this is
but this is not this is not using
Christianity right this is outright
[__] hate speech like you oh yeah
this person is calling for the public
execution and genocide of all lgbtq
people
and the parents of them as well I don't
know if you caught that so if your child
is lgbtq he believes that you should be
publicly executed you should be shot in
the back of the head
as CB says that guy's speech isn't free
it's tax exempt well
that's why we need to tax the churches
full stop if you're a church [__] you
you're taxed you don't get an exemption
not anymore not in this country not with
speech like this not with nonsense like
this
um and the reason why I played it last
night on the patreon for the patreon
members and a lot of people I opened it
up to the public so a lot of people
probably saw that last night but I
wanted to make sure to show it today in
this context that Martha Green Lauren
bobert they may not really believe what
this guy's saying
but this guy thinks they do yeah this
guy thinks that there are [__] state
governments there's Governors there's
Congress people there's Senators out
there that believe what he's saying
because my guess is is that Jason
Grabber Pastor Grabber here
who claims to be a Christian needs to
have his electronic storage device is
checked my guess is is that this is a
lot of projection well he's doing a lot
of research telling me Oh yeah sermons
he's got to know exactly what the little
kids are being forced to do in these
very exposed settings right he wants to
see these things happen so he knows
exactly how to talk about them not for
not for pleasure right or personal it's
for business for God
speaking of Forgotten for Jesus did you
know Lauren Bowers I mean Margaret
Taylor Green's getting a divorced but
Lauren Bowers getting a divorce too did
you know that I did and did you know
that her new boyfriend is threatening to
sue anyone who says that out loud
no yeah apparently he's threatening to
sue anyone who tries to defame him by
claiming that him and Lauren bobert are
[__] are [__] each other and he's
cheating on his wife he claims that he's
going to sue anybody and everybody who
claims okay take me to court I'll say it
do it let's go through the discovery
process I can't wait I got literally
nothing to hide and whatever what it
pertains to this guy send the C and D to
me [__] let's do it Mayo had one
of the best one of the best Tweets
though our friend Mayo here on the show
um she's been a viewer since the very
beginning too John Cooper tweeted a
photo and I'll show you the photo in a
minute and he says caption this
she says the Dukes of Hazard and here he
is there's Lauren Boward and her new
boyfriend uh Liam Nissan is calling him
what Raymond what is it Ramen Ramen um
something I forget what it is oh my God
oh this guy this guy we showed a clip of
this guy a few weeks ago do you remember
it yep you remember the clip can you
pull that clip up because he's the same
he's the same he's he's of the same
degenerate Christian nationalist
as Pastor grabber
he's same [__] same [__]
and I'm gonna show you I'm gonna show
you yeah someone's saying ramen noodles
yeah that's it Ramen Shaman that's it
that's it
um money librarian here's Edward The
Ramen Shop
come on man that's hilarious the ramen
Shaman his [__] hair looks like Ramen
noodles look at this gay look at this
[__] gay he looks like so you know
how people used to make fun of uh Justin
Timberlake yeah and they were like oh
look he's got that Ramen here this is
like uh this is actually Ramen here this
is this is here the shoes ever one is
one is Justin Timberlake from NSYNC the
90s uh early 2000s that hair is
uh Ramen when it's still dry and
dehydrated this guy is ramen when it's
full like right in boil yeah right right
that's I I think so let's see if we can
find that uh video where he's he's
talking about how God should run the
government and Christianity should run
the government because that's that's
great here's another here's another take
on the picture too
um if you want to see this is a this is
just a filter of that same picture
um if you um
oh my God the internet was running wild
with it this weekend and um about this
um who is Lauren bobert actually
schlubbing right why why is she
divorcing that [__] of a husband of hers
Jason with a Y you know when you're like
Jason with a Y you're a [__] right well
I mean did you notice did you notice
everyone's been using the word [__]
online did you see that I have not seen
that yeah goats go on Twitter and search
the word [__]
I mean not yet maybe later not right now
which video do you want again
there's there's so many that popped up
so many that popped up when the ramen
shop when you search the ramen Shaman
yeah oh boy that's not good
um the one where he's talking about how
Jesus and Christianity should run our
government is the one okay all right I
think I think Patriot takes at it I have
it on my timeline somewhere but he the
[__] knows
um but uh okay oh boy these people oh
Lauren boobert
so Lauren bobert is a [__] box and
um
she is definitely
um doing somebody right I mean everyone
knows this this isn't hard I know
everybody's doing somebody right I mean
I'm sure I'm sure Margaret Taylor green
and Laura bobert were at all those
cocaine sex parties right am I am I
wrong I mean come on are you gonna doubt
me on that do you do you think they were
both at these cocaine sex parties I
think it's possible man I'm going deep
and now there's all these videos of him
from January 1st 2022 where what's he
saying it's a bunch of covet stuff and
he's healing he's healing Casey to say
oh give me that give me that yeah he's
healing Casey DeSantis ah yeah let's
launch that one I want to watch them but
yeah let's go after the ramen Shaman
let's do that all right I'm all about it
hell we got we got 30 minutes left
oh [__] I mean I had a few other videos
that I wanted to show
um uh Paulie says Australian have to use
[__]
yeah see we had a lot of we got a lot of
um Australians that watch us so and a
lot of people are terrified of the word
[__] they're terrified of it why it's
just a [__] word
um and that that and it doesn't mean
what you think it means it's good man
dude this oh my God how did I never see
these videos how do you see his how do
you say his last name is it fetch that
what it is spec fascist well you know a
German friend of mine sent me wait wait
wait let me look it up uh so anyways a
friend of mine German friend of mine who
is uh from that region of the world he
sent me a thing and he said his last
name literally his last name translates
in German to moist
this guy this Voit
[Laughter]
it means moist yeah so it's the same
moist foit
wait wait wait wait
you remember the um the yeah bye bye bye
bye yeah
oh this is a video of Lauren bobert's
lover
apparently healing Casey DeSantis Rhonda
Santos's wife this is gonna be awesome
if you want to know the truth let's
listen we're gonna sing
for the promotion that we haven't
received for the Salvation of our loved
ones it hasn't happened yet for the for
the healing of cancer listen I felt like
when we were on stage tonight and I laid
hands on the governor and his wife whoa
whoa
what what the [__] did he just say did
he lay his hands on the governor and his
wife whoa he laid hands on him man I
want to see that video of him laying
hands on him what the [__] okay let's
now play the next video then well let's
listen to the rest I want to hear the
rest of this one and then we'll go to
the next one I told her this I looked at
her in the eyes and I'm saying God is
going to heal you
[Music]
that's not how cancer works but okay I
thought he totally was gonna say God is
gonna come inside you and heal the
cancer I died
[__] you into healing I totally thought
that's what he was gonna say the idea
that they're like oh God is gonna heal
you that's guys that's not how cancer
works right why would if God again it's
like school shootings for children and
and innocent people
why would God allow these things to
happen right if there is evil in the
world why would God not prevent it right
if there are people with cancer and
diseases
and illnesses why would he not do you
know the same thing you know use use a
messenger like his son Jesus Christ
and heal these people who are who are
ill right uh and in this way this is
some guy Griffin off the idea that if
you just pray hard enough
the cancer right you just gotta you just
gotta lay hands yeah on him and Jesus
will come inside you and get rid of that
cancer let's listen
I'm not saying that is fluff I believe
it in my spirit there's an anointing for
healing here tonight how many believe me
[Music]
we're gonna oh my God this is wild [__]
let's listen what's the next one the
next one is them on stage so I haven't
watched the full thing but it's him
getting an award
wait wait wait wait who on stage Ron
DeSantis in Casey DeSantis oh is this
where he lays hands and Jesus I'm
assuming again I haven't watched the
whole thing I haven't watched the whole
thing yet but I think this is what he's
talking about here's her a cancer okay
so this is this is what he was talking
about this is the interaction
Hey listen why were people making fun of
Chris Christie for being fat you see how
[__] chubby Rhonda Santos is and I'm
not trying to body shame people but damn
if you're gonna comment Chris Christie
for being chubby have the same energy
for this every Republican candidate that
is running right is uh well Tim Scott
Tim Scott isn't that big and Asia Assa
Hutchison that's what I collector Assa
Hutchinson Vivek isn't that big
oh you think there's more than one
guys I don't know if you should be fat
shaming each other because right man
it's like you know even if you remember
the post that he made on Truth social
last year he was talking about Chris
Christie at like 11 p.m at a whatever
that restaurant was where he was like
getting you know food out of the tray
and it's like man you are not one to
[__] comment on someone's weight okay
right you are not the fittest president
we've ever had you are the most
unhealthy I mean Joe Biden Joe Biden
might be old but he can ride a [__]
bike yeah yeah I mean he can hop up on a
bike can you imagine what would happen
to the bike if Donald Trump's ass said
does Donald Trump know how to ride a
bike no I have a I have a strong inkling
there he's probably never really he
never learned because his dad didn't
love him and that's the unfortunate
reality of the Trump family how it works
kids need hugs and this guy obviously
didn't get a hug either let's listen and
see how
um maybe Jesus comes inside of Casey
DeSantis and cures her cancer I don't
know and so thank you and keep fighting
keep fighting he's so awkward back down
and don't let them drive you down God
bless you all thank you so much what's
the I mean I get the whole effect with
the the angel hollering in the
background do you hear that because
that's a track that's just a track right
right it's kind of weird right is it
supposed to all right stop it damn it
I mean like that Guiding Light they're
like all right hit the misters go all
right now it's behind the light okay
right I mean man this is what's crazy
about this is that this is the one
reason why people are so [__] easily
mind [__] right because they get they
get these they they get them in this
emotional state and they get them
wrapped up in this and then they act
like they're gonna make cure cancer on
stage and those people they're they're
so [__] into it and so intense yeah
that they end up trying to believe it
it's kind of like I don't know like I
say all the time we're at their
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life where you go to wrestling event and
they're slamming each other on the mat
and they're [__] throwing each other
and they're acting hurt maybe they're
bleeding or they got blood capsules and
they're yelling and screaming at each
other and you're like yeah man I mean
you're all [__] fired up there's the
[__] music and the goddamn lights and
the [__] pyrotechnics like yeah this
is [__] real I know it's fake but
it's [__] real right like that's kind
of the vibe I'm getting here but let's
let's listen uh to more
[Applause]
come on give him a hand
listen we
we were here in in in February how many
guys were there at West Palm Beach
and the Lord did something really
profound in our hearts and in this
movement and thank the Lord that we
found people that were willing to fight
they were trying to fight I'm not gonna
lie you know what this makes me want to
do this makes me want to just quit this
show and go on the road and be some kind
of [__] weirdest Pastor grifter I
mean honestly what the [__] why the [__]
not I mean really why the hell not I
mean this apparently this guy went from
making a 100 Grand a year and and all of
a sudden like in 2020 he made like five
or six million dollars I'm not [__]
you I mean he's got multiple businesses
and from what I understand they're all
questionably taking or did questionably
taken PPP loan money
[Music]
um that seems kind of weird yeah it's a
little bit uh I don't know I mean like
uh the tax return was it was revealed
yesterday online and so a lot of people
are asking questions how you go from a
couple hundred thousand to five million
it feels like this guy's gonna probably
get indicted soon it's probably yeah
that's what it is
good [__] them especially when he's like
I'll sue anyone who says anything about
me who types my name but let's listen to
how he healed the Santa's wife now I
remember this moment because I think
this was still when covet was going
around yeah this was January 1st 2012.
and she she couldn't get vaccinated or
some [__] and she's cancerous there and
they didn't refuse to wear masks at this
event and all kinds of [__] and there
she is with cancer but anyway let's
listen find us for worship we fought we
fought we fought thanks to the help from
the governor's office we beat the fines
and it really set a mark for us for the
next 100 cities the Lord did something
in Florida so we're honored to be back
in your state and we wanted to present
you with something and pray for you if
that's okay this is the 2021 Defender oh
Jesus Christ presented to Governor
Rhonda Sanchez would you just thank him
again
thank him again
he is a fighter and we are do you think
is he a fighter do you think he threw
that thing directly in the trash
probably how much you know how much of a
fighter Ron DeSantis is uh he he would
not do or say anything in response to
Donald Trump when he made fun of him for
eating [__] pudding fingers he
laughed ha ha like you laughed it off
like that and that's all he did
weird stuff the guy's a [__] [__]
man I'll just say it he's a [__] ass
[__] they all are Donald Trump Ron
DeSantis Chris Christie you know vivec
[__] Tim Scott they're all [__]
cowards you call them out they say that
you're the bully you call them out for
their hypocrisy they're they're double
standards their racism their bigotry
there's xenophobia they're they're
transphobia they're homophobia like
anything they go oh that's not nice you
can't say that you can't do that
it's like no I'm gonna use my First
Amendment right and I'm going to speak
out against you and expose the lies
that you have told
and the hypocrisy that you spread and
the hate that you spew and they get
really upset and they're like I'm gonna
Sue anyone who defames my name it's like
is it defamatory if it's true well you
know what I want to tell the audience
please don't do that don't go on social
media and defame him or say his name and
post pictures to him and Bowers say
their relationship please whatever you
do yeah don't make him send out millions
of cease or actually actually what you
could do is you just ask a question
right you just put it at the end instead
of saying these two guys are [__] you
say are these two guys [__] right
question mark I'm just asking questions
and then you post a photo that's a good
question and then you put arrows and you
say [__] question mark this is the
question you're not making accusation
you're just asking a question I don't
know it's funny speaking of Florida uh
since they were in Florida I found a
video this morning on Twitter and it it
might get your Fields up here this guy
this guy
he gives no [__] like he is no [__]
someone actually went in uh they quote
tweeted Mike Mike tweet and they were
like
they said something like oh this would
be great if there was not such foul
language it was it was this would be
great if there were no swear words oh
yeah that's right so so that a younger
demographic could could see it I'm like
no swear words the [__] off get the [__]
out of here with that [__] no there
should be swear words in this thing it's
the exact reason why I posted it [__]
so deal with it but here is um I think
his name is Dixon White NOW Dixon white
won on Tic Tac here's his take on
Florida and why Rhonda Santos is the
governor of Florida he doesn't think
it's because Florida's inherently red
yeah he just believes that people were
voting for white supremacy and they may
not even have known it let's listen
white supremacy always said it and I'll
say it again you [__] yourself look at
the [__] State of Florida State of
Florida is becoming a [__] Sundown
Town you're not a straight white
Christian male and he's going for them
too everybody's civil liberties and
constitutional rights are being affected
let me know let me tell you something
you guys always say it's gerrymandering
all that [__] while I get elected no 68
of Cubans voted for DeSantis 58 of
Puerto Ricans 53 of all Latinos voted
for the Sanchez God knows how many white
ignorant [__] you buy a new
white supremacy you don't care it's not
your problem you're a [__] idiot it
is your [__] problem
white supremacy affects everybody not
just black people not just Brown
billions indigenous people everybody now
you elected a [__] fascist in the
State of Florida now you gotta deal with
your civil liberties being violated now
you gotta deal with businesses
Industries being shut down because they
can't find any [__] labor and now
magically Latinos give a [__] Latinos
didn't give a [__] when when he was
anti-black with his anti-woke policy you
didn't give a [__] now that it's
anti-immigration now you give a [__]
well guess what you got what you [__]
voted for you [__] idiots at all
Cubans diction not all Puerto Ricans
Dixon not all white people Dixie I know
not all but two [__] many the
majority of you people voted for fascism
the majority of you people voted for
white supremacy that's the [__]
problem you you don't care you haven't
done anything to address it address the
[__] problem hold your people
accountable I'm half Cuban I know it's
in my own [__] family some of them I
know what it Spike in the [__] Cuban
Community I've seen in my own [__]
eyes the other half is white God knows
the white supremacy and ignorance
racially that operates in my white
Community hold your people accountable
so that you don't have this kind of
[__] [__] I'm not saying
Democrats aren't racist but [__] man
they're not going to these extreme to
normalize white supremacy in the
normalized fascism past legislation that
is directly
anti-immigrant anti-gay
anti-black and coming for every other
Liberty that you have
my God people are [__] ignorant I've
always told you people white supremacy
hurts
so um I couldn't agree or with Dixon
there
um
I I wanted to show it because I know
we've talked about this before and we've
talked about it with Texas Paul because
he experienced it in South Texas he's
like yeah it's weird where Hispanics are
voting against what seems to be against
their interest and and we've talked
about it a lot before
um and because you have some experience
with this in this community and now
Dixon says he's
um half Cuban I believe he said and and
half white and you know maybe he
experiences the same [__] where he's not
wide enough and he's not you know Cuban
enough type stuff that you've talked
about with your experience before but
when you when you feel this video
because it is about his feelings right
and that's where the [__] come out
right that's where this [__] comes out
what what it what what grabs you the
most about what he's saying because I
think it's important with messaging that
we understand what is grabbing people
the most what grabs you the most in the
Bible I mean just the I mean just the no
[__] given attitude I think is first
off that's amazing but the the main
thing is the act at the aspect of
holding our communities accountable
right not not letting them just run amok
and vote for the one thing that they you
know that they may not be aware of right
and stealing and instigating and
spreading this white supremacy type of
narrative within the party like you may
not know that right and or they may not
know that and and you are aware but I
think that our responsibility is to hold
our community accountable and say do you
know what you're supporting by voting
for this guy do you know who sits at the
table and waves their flags at the
speaking conventions or engagements that
he does do you know exactly what he
represents he represents the complete
opposite of your existence he does not
want you to exist well the the other
thing too that I think is important um
in the messaging that Dixon's trying to
you know convey here when you say that
hold our communities accountable because
it's not just about Latinos or or and
it's more specifically Cubans Puerto
Ricans Mexicans
um this is about women the community of
women the community of white men the
community of CIS white men the community
of gay men the community of gay women
everyone has their communities right
everyone has their communities and they
can be niched down all they can and we
have to hold them accountable and more
communities need to be held accountable
than others especially the white dudes
that look like me okay that's probably
the one that needs to be held most
accountable to their decisions and their
actions that are setting our country
back
um and but I think that's the point is
that we can't we can't knock out me all
right we can't discount these
communities right like we can't discount
Cuban Americans we can't discount Puerto
Rican Americans especially in Florida
um but we have to we have to hold them
accountable but we also have to speak to
them the way that they they want right
hear it because so many times
Democrats or leftists speak over top of
someone or speak at someone right and
it's what causes this problem that Dixon
is pointing out right like oh you were
okay with voting for DeSantis when he
was going after the black folks right
awoke which is amazing that Dixon pulled
woke because I was saying from the very
beginning whoop means black yeah quote
means black now I mean you know Florida
is where Wilkos to die I mean it's not
you know the dog whistle isn't silent
it's pretty [__] loud if you listen
to it right well and and Dixon picks up
on that right but then he says now that
he's done [__] to affect you and your
livelihood now you're pissed right you
knew this was gonna happen if he was
going to do it to them he would do it to
you and that's that's all the narrative
that needs to be pushed here right look
yes is Donald Trump going to be the
nominee of course and Joe Biden's going
to be the nominee on Democratic side and
that race is almost a [__] slam dunk
we just have to do our jobs right right
and I don't mean me and Gabe I mean
everyone everyone in democrac see if we
do our job there's no [__] way Donald
Trump will ever become president ever
again if we do our jobs in democracy but
we all we can't we can't just do that
job we have to do the job to take back
the house right we got to do the job of
increasing the amount of senators that
we have that are serious about policy
and the only party that's serious is
Democrats we have to do a damn serious
good job
in these states to take away these super
majorities of Republicans make force
them to walk away from these ideas
because they can't do [__] they don't
have a super majority it's it's just
it's just the cold hard facts and Dixon
is spot on with this yes it's some of it
very uncomfortable when he says it
absolutely 100 yeah but that's the thing
it's like making making you feel
uncomfortable means that there's
something that you should be like wait
wait okay one why do I do uncomfortable
exactly and two like what is he saying
where you might be like Oh I'm gonna
look this up I'm gonna look I'm gonna
double check those stats he's like oh
[__] he's actually right about those
things right or like whatever it might
be the the fact that it makes you feel
something that's the fact that it makes
you feel uncomfortable means that
there's something there
that you're that you might be like okay
something doesn't feel right and I
should I should look into this more I
should understand why what and at least
at least at least trying to understand
the underlying narrative which is
beautiful right speaking of underlying
narratives you sent me um grandpa poopy
pantses true social so and I don't know
if people know this big announcement
breaking news it's not it's not that
breakable yeah did you see that Howard
Dean moment that he had today who Tim
Scott uh-huh he did oh yeah at the
beginning yeah I heard that but he was
like yeah where he was like uh
sure was he in Charleston or is he yeah
he was like it's great to be back in
South Carolina where I haven't been in a
long time it was I don't know it's
really weird
and it's like oh Beauty puberty hits you
just now wow yeah well uh Tim Scott
believes that apparently he's the most
dangerous candidate for leftists out
there because he's black listen friend I
Tim I I get it I get what you're doing
Uncle Tom but I don't think the black
community is buying it okay I just don't
think they are go ask Herschel Walker
how that worked out just go ask him go
ask him how that worked out but here's
Grandpa booby pants on Tim Scott
entering the race now again I keep
telling you
I know I know I know everyone thinks I'm
wrong but trust me on this I am
absolutely 100 right and I'm gonna be
right on this whether you like it or not
no matter what analyst you watch on TV
no matter what stupid [__] person
who's been doing this for 20 30 years
tells you I'm Gonna Be Right Donald
Trump is going to be the nominee every
other person entering the race is going
to attack Ron DeSantis that's why Donald
Trump is bringing up Ron DeSantis so
that they all attack him because they're
all vying for second place because they
have to be second to beat Trump okay got
it and follow watch what he watch what
he says here good luck
to Senator Tim Scott in entering the
Republican presidential primary race it
is rapidly loading up with lots of
people and Tim is a big step up from Ron
the sanctimonious who is totally
unelectable I got opportunity zones done
with Tim a big deal that has been highly
successful and you know when he says
that it's been [__] absolutely a [__]
disaster but he goes on to say good luck
Tim now again I believe that Tim Scott
is getting in this race for Donald Trump
that's right yeah I said it he's got 22
million dollars he's gonna dump 22
million dollars on DeSantis Chris
Christie's gonna get in this race and
Destroy Ron DeSantis and it's going to
help Trump these people ending the race
is not going to hurt Trump it's going to
help him and if you're not if you're if
you think Trump is not going to be
nominee you do not understand how Cults
work you're not getting it yet he he's
got his cult they're going to vote for
him no matter what no matter what no
matter what and the rest of these
[__] boneheads splitting up what's
left of this affiliation vote ain't
gonna amount to [__] hella beans and
delegates at the Republican National
Convention next summer right and Ron and
Donald Trump
he's going to walk in to the convention
or he'll be sitting in the jail
somewhere and be calling it in he's
going to win on the first [__] ballot
mark my it's May 22nd Monday 1 50 p.m
eastern time and I'm gonna say it 100
times if I don't say it a million
Donald Trump is going to win on the
first ballot got it that's what's going
to happen and Tim Scott Chris Christie
and all these other [__] chuckleheads
entering this race is only guaranteeing
it at this point there's a part of
there's a part of me that looks at Ron
De Santa like I don't even know what you
call
Ron desantis's followers right
but I have a feeling
uh that Ron DeSantis supporters are
going to be like Bernie Bros
oh they're gonna be like they're gonna
be like
all the way to the convention type [__]
yeah they're gonna take it all the way
the Little D's that's what you call them
little Little D's Little D's yeah yeah
yeah yeah hey boom we got it little D's
so little D's are going to uh they're
gonna show up all the way they're gonna
try and protest it and you know they're
gonna lose
and then and then on Election Day right
they're either gonna make the decision
to not vote or vote for Biden oh boy
like I feel like that's on because
because what they're gonna do is like
well he didn't win this one so we'll get
it we'll get him in the next election
but until then we gotta [__] Trump over
so I think these little D's
really got to get they gotta Corral
together to get that energy that little
D energy you know they got a little bit
energy they gotta work together
so that they can protest Trump being
president
or they're gonna yeah I think
I think we did I think they're I think
it's going to be Little D energy all the
way to the convention and they're either
not going to vote for for Donald Trump
or they're going to vote for Biden and I
think it's going to be a small margin of
that vote for Biden but I think there's
me a greater margin of people who just
don't vote all together well or rather
don't vote for the presidential
candidate so there is in that Twitter
space uh with Lauren Loomer there was
some uh Trump supporters and there were
some the sanus reporters supporters and
the DeSantis supporters were saying well
if DeSantis doesn't win then I'll vote
for Trump but the Trump voters like [__]
no I'll never vote for DeSantis he can
go to hell it and again I keep I keep
trying to tell people this but they're
not listening you don't know how Cults
work you're not understanding what is
what what he has done here to your party
you don't fundamentally understand what
he has done to your party you guys went
balls deep in the midterm that you were
guaranteed to win and you lost
everywhere okay everywhere you've lost
you dumb [__] you went balls
deep into trumpism in the cult and
you've lost but it didn't matter because
the cult wanted it that's what you
boneheads don't understand and I'm gonna
give you proof right here let's check in
on Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
in the house on how culty they are
listen to this [__] listen to what he's
gonna do this is great this is another
gift thank you please gym I don't report
sex crimes Jordan do this let's hear it
real quick
wrote that while they were pursuing
Trump they made no effort to investigate
the claim that Hillary Clinton was
taking money from Foreigners for her
Clinton Global initiative and the
Clinton Foundation
foreign
they not only did investigate her like
they did President Trump they gave her
campaign a defensive briefing
for president Trump because they
literally had no evidence so we're going
to talk with our lawyers we're going to
talk with speaker McCarthy yeah on where
we proceed from from here in fact are
there people that were that were
highlighted in the Durham investigation
sure the German report that we needed to
be here we hear your [__] we're
going to give that a good hard look but
nothing is off the table because it is
critical the American people understand
how their government their agencies have
been turned on them the taxpayer and we
get all the facts out there
please do this please step on this rake
will you please this is like the biggest
rake that you're gonna step on I mean
two weeks ago remember Joe Biden was
gonna have to [__] resign his office
because they were going to uncover all
the Chinese well James James Comer was
like oh I just want to say to the doj
please do not indict Hunter Biden before
my conference on Wednesday right and I
don't know why they would because well
you know whatever but at the same time
it's like you had [__] Jack diddly
Squat and and and I said it in my what
was that which is Republicans like James
Comer and Jim Jordan and all these other
people on the Republican lawmaker side
for for you know Representatives
Senators whatever
they have to lean into the fact that
they that they need to string their
their base along they can't show them
the evidence because they don't have any
evidence so they have to waste taxpayer
money string them along and say look
we've got this other thing that's coming
out but we can't tell you during this
interview but we want to keep you
engaged so look out look out it'll come
out in two weeks it'll come out in two
weeks and then what you see is that they
have nothing they have absolutely
nothing
and they're already [__] whining and
crying about there's a lack of arrest to
to the Biden family Hunter Biden Joe
Biden all these other people they say
are the swamp
and their base is fuckling clamoring for
more arrests
in the Republican Party hasn't been able
to prove [__] do you know what um the
average American
doesn't want anyone to do at this point
bring up more investigations into
Hillary [__] Clinton they're gonna be
like wait a sec you're doing what okay
you're you're telling me I can't [__]
afford gas or groceries you're telling
me gas stoves M M's targets and Bud
Light are my enemy and you're going to
investigate [__] Hillary Clinton you
promised the laptop and you fell short
and you're telling me you're opening up
another investigation into Bill and
Hillary Clinton are you [__] me you
think people are going to be excited
about that I mean yeah there's some
[__] brain dead idiots your Uncle
Earl or the guy down the street that
still has the tattered Chinese made
Trump flag on his front porch that are
going to be like yeah Hillary put that
[__] in jail yeah lock her up sure
certainly but it's not enough it's not
enough folks it's not enough I want to
say
40 million or more on the Benghazi
you remember that what did it prove what
did it prove Republicans are [__]
idiots exactly and I was like dude let's
do it again I I am willing I am willing
to put 40 million dollars worth of
taxpayers money on another investigation
to Hillary Clinton that absolutely makes
Republicans look like [__] fools we
wasted that is totally worth that amount
of money six to seven million dollars on
the Durham report that was a flop right
like I don't know how many more examples
we have to show you guys
and I know the audience understands but
like just people in general that when
Republicans are like we're gonna find
this person who committed this crime
okay great go investigate go look around
if you find something if you have
legitimate concrete evidence that this
person committed a crime or they were
involved in some sort of conspiracy with
other people to commit a crime then
[__] Bring It Forward give it to the
doj but if you hold a Committee hearing
multiple committee hearings with no
proof with whistleblowers that were paid
by [__] cash Patel whistleblowers
that you say oh well how are things
about the family they have to be paid by
the government and now all of a sudden
you [__] support government
government like assistance get the [__]
out of here and the idea that you're
like oh well it's only we only support
whistleblowers who benefit our narrative
right exactly even though they're not
real whistleblowers
they're paid operatives and like can we
just talk about how [__] Republicans
all of a sudden support whistleblowers
but they run away from people literally
blowing whistles at their rallies well
that is kind of a weird thing Doug says
hey Doug says on YouTube I know jack
[__] I don't know who jack [__] is I
really don't I don't know who that is
I've never I've never heard of him um if
you can tell me who that is Doug then
that would be great because I I I don't
I don't know Jack and the third thing is
they're thinking Jack Jack's Jack Smith
Smith uh I don't know him either well I
know I've read a lot about it and I
would say that there's going to be a
certain someone that's going to be
terrified of him terrified of it
especially when your former lawyers are
like hey man that's pretty good oh my
God and now I gotta play that clip I was
gonna play the clip of um bobert's new
moist boyfriend his uh the ramen Shaman
yeah
hi my name is what is it Brian Sean
moist oh Sean Moy Shawn moist yeah see
that's how that's how ramen relevant he
is to me I thought his name was Brian I
was thinking of maybe Brian Glenn that's
uh well let me show this clip yeah yeah
of uh Sean moist here bobert's new love
boy
um
let's listen to how he wants God to rule
the country and then we'll go back to
Trump's lawyer because I want to play
that clip too we're gonna you got a few
minutes yeah I got a few minutes one
over like five minutes all right okay
okay it's all part of the king coming
back
that's what we're practicing for
that's why that's why hell hates it that
we're worshiping at every Capitol Across
America what what
that's why we get called well you're
Christian nationalists you want you yeah
you are the kingdom
we know you do yeah we know you do you
[__] fascist thank God you're coming
over take the government yes yeah we
know you're a Christian
only was it yes we did we know you're
bigots yeah we got it yeah
um
[Music]
control that isn't no neighbors to be
the ones writing the Lots yes guilty as
charged
I mean it's funny when I meet Christians
where I'm like I don't really I'm not
really I'm like have you read the Great
Commission like this is actually what we
want
guilty he is guilty oh man he said it
there what's crazy is uh the ramen the
ramen Shaman I wonder if we call his
followers the Raman Davidians
for uh Lauren bobert's new love man
there
um I'm glad I got that so let's go back
to the the clip of the attorney so
um Donald Trump's one of his attorneys
had to go testify before Jack Smith and
I was forced to testify
um and apparently this morning there's
news that uh the another attorney oh my
God another Trump attorney
um had the attorney claim privilege
exception revoked and had to give over
his notes and apparently
apparently there was obstruction oh my
God how did we not note this I mean I
look I called it before when he said you
know they're they're not coming for me
they're coming from you they're coming
for you guys it's like no they're really
coming for you right they're really
coming for you but also when he's like
I'm gonna keep standing in their way
okay dude that's obstruction
well it's the craziest part is this
attorney describes uh Boris Epstein who
is a long time Trump advisor and uh also
a Russian who is who is also at the
arraignment in New York City and yes yes
he was because he's because he thinks
he's a lawyer he thinks he is I mean
he's past his bar but this guy explains
at the end
right well and he explains why he isn't
really an actual lawyer but listen
listen to what he's saying out loud I
mean he's saying it between the lines
where he's yelling at he's trying to
scream it that Boris and Trump are doing
listen to this infighting is certainly
nothing new uh in in Trump World Is
there any specific instance of something
that he did to as you say prevent you
from being able to properly represent
your client oh sure I mean there was he
served as kind of a um filter what is he
a [__] cigarette a filter a filter
Boris I've seen as a builder come on man
give me a break
you've already seen filtering let's
let's listen to what he's filtering
let's see what crimes he's trying to
filter here to prevent us from getting
information to the client and getting
information from the client uh in my
opinion he was not very honest with us
or oh not very honest wow that you know
what that's called that's called um
lying oh and I just want to make sure
I'm pointing it out yeah Big L Big L and
if you're writing things down on an
official statement for the courts lying
in court is called um what's that called
perjury yeah
and and it comes with charges possibly
and it can be criminal charges of
perjury it's kind of funny I just I just
want to point that out that that
attorney is saying that uh let's keep
going see what other things crimes Boris
was quietly trying to uh commit with the
client on certain things uh there were
certain things like the searches that he
had attempted to interfere with oh
he starts with an o yeah
obstruction yeah that's it hmm kind of
funny right I don't know I'm just saying
hmm okay let's keep going see if there's
any more crimes Trump former lawyer is
admitting to here that Boris and jumper
committee let's let's keep going and
then more recently as we're coming down
to the end of this investigation where
Jack Smith and ultimately Merrick
Garland is going to make a decision as
to what to do as we put together our
defense strategy uh to help educate
America I love how he says that to help
educate Merrick Garland that's what he
said to help educate in other words the
argument that we're trying to make to
make sure that Merrick Garland doesn't
indict Donald Trump that's what he's
trying to say that's what he's trying to
say folks we are going to try to we were
trying to convince Merrick Garland
because ultimately Merrick Garland takes
the advice of Jack Smith takes the
recommendations of Jack Smith and either
says yes I'm not going to stand in the
way of this or no no no I got to stand
in the way of this right one way or the
other he's gonna have the final call the
final shot here and that's what this guy
is saying because this guy is saying
Jack Smith is definitely indicting
Donald Trump no question the attorney is
saying Donald Trump is going to be
indicted by Jack Smith in this interview
he's not saying it out loud you got to
read between lines when he's saying it
but he's also saying our last line to
defense was to convince mayor Garland
not to do this and Boris Epstein is
standing in the way of that strategy
keep listening all right Garland as to
how best uh to handle this matter he was
preventing us from engaging in that
strategy uh you said that Boris tried to
prevent you from conducting searches
this is the great this is the searches
at uh Bedminster whoa whoa wait what
searches at Bedminster wait a second
that's not Mar-A-Lago yeah what's going
on there I don't know why would Morris
Epstein have why would he want the
lawyers the lawyers not to search
Bedminster for classified documents it's
almost like there's something there they
don't want them to see yeah why would
you why would you ever say Rob says
Digger up I mean look we've said it
before there's there's boxes that went
from a truck to a plane were those could
you fit eight boxes in that casket
probably why do you need so many people
carrying the actual casket
also if she was cremated what the [__]
you carrying the thing for on our merch
store there is Digger up shirts I'm just
saying you you should go check them out
just go to the Tony michaels.com go to
the merch store you can check out the
Digger up shirts I'm serious they're on
there they let me put them on there I
don't know them okay let's uh let's
finish what Timothy has to say here
about boris's uh law experience because
that's probably the best that's a cherry
on the top
um initially uh there was a lot of
pushback from him where he didn't want
us doing the search and we had to
eventually overcome him
why didn't you overcome him I don't know
you know Boris is
you know he's
been about 18 months at a big firm doing
transactional work and I think he just
thinks based on that experience he knows
better than all of us
by Boris Epstein so Absol and Owl also
the attorney's like thank goodness I
don't know what's at Bedminster you know
well the other thing too I think the
attorney the reason why this attorney is
out doing interviews is because he knows
he's in hot [__] and he better get out
in front of this and let everyone know
that hey one me that was obstructing
[__] one me I was trying to do my
[__] job Boris Epstein and Donald
Trump are the ones obstructed and they
were the ones committing perjury they
are the ones who are lying it's them
them them and the other attorneys not me
not me I'm actually I'm yeah they're
like look guys I knew
I took the job but now I know I
shouldn't have taken the job right right
I'm doing the good I'm actually telling
you guys about what's going on look at
this guy he's real sus everyone's like
yeah we already knew he was us but right
thank you for adding details about
badminster which we didn't know right
and and the actual lying that Boris and
Donald Trump were doing and the
obstruction that they're doing thank you
very much for adding that context into
the public sphere now again he's making
us read between the lines because he
can't outright say this right but he
knows it he [__] knows it to be true
and he's trying to cast his narrative
into the public that it wasn't me wasn't
me
caught her on the counter wasn't me in
the bedroom I don't remember the song Do
You Remember the lyrics no yeah it's
like every single room in the house
wasn't me yeah that's it that's it it's
a Shaggy song I was banging on the sofa
what does it mean
it sounds like a Lauren bobert Marjorie
Taylor green spoof I'm just saying
I'm just saying
all right well I think I took it way too
far
um thanks for trying the Tony Michaels
podcast uh you know you can see us every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right
here on YouTube Twitter and twitch make
sure to subscribe here on YouTube hit
the Subscribe button hit the like button
don't fail to do that also follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you can
download every single episode on Apple's
Spotify and Google you can also watch it
over on Facebook at the Tony Michaels go
watch it on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels holy [__] I have been paying
attention we are so close to 200
subscribers on Twitch
you can follow us on Twitch for free it
does not cost a single nickel to follow
us but if you want to subscribe for free
as well if you're an Amazon Prime user
listen to me if you have an Amazon Prime
account what you can do is link your
Prime account to your Twitch account and
you get one free subscription every
single month and every single month you
can give us the Tony Michaels podcast
that subscription on our Channel on
YouTube and we get a couple bucks every
month we got a goal of 200 we're at 191.
190 was over nine away from getting 200
subscribers so if you have a Prime
account it is free for you to link it
with your Twitch account and give us two
dollars ever it's like two dollars seven
cents time they take their cut
it's like 4.99 to start with and that's
all we get but hey it's free for you to
give it to us and it's great monetary
support for us so we appreciate everyone
who does that and who renews it every
single month you have to renew it every
single month free money isn't easy money
but it's pretty cool so I appreciate all
the support over on Twitch
oh man what do you think what what kind
of crazy [__] are we gonna have tomorrow
you think oh I don't know man uh I have
not even I have not looked at any events
that are happening this week but you
think you think Little D and the Little
D's get in do you think he gets in in it
when you announce
when you're running like a fundraiser or
if you're launching like a product or an
app you typically will do it on a
Tuesday right so you don't lose it in
the weekend Shuffle and then you'll do
Thursday
um sometimes you announce like like on a
I don't know I mean I think it's got
really really I mean he made it obvious
that he's running dude he [__] up so
bad the microphone was like shut up man
shut up the microphone shut off and did
not only he was like I honestly thought
it was an audio like I thought there was
something [__] up on the video what a
poor guy oh no poor guy
this is this is running straight into
the campaign Trail and [__] stepping
on the rake immediately
immediately uh well that's the whole
intention that's whole intention to Tim
Scott is to run for Donald Trump to hurt
Ron DeSantis I'm telling you that's what
it is come back tomorrow for the same
crazy commentary here on the Tony
Michaels podcast we always bring the
energy we always bring the heat it's
real troll it's right here same time
same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__]
[__] up
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon